les ukrainiens ne cessent d'arriver dans
la capitale polonaise des voyageurs bien
malgré eux souvent chargé et fatigue
l'angoissé des nuits difficiles se lit
sur les visages
lentement parfois avec hésitation il
monta laitages et découvre toute la
générosité de leur voisins
polonais kouba tchaïkovski ne compte
plus les heures passées à la gare
centrale fin février il a été l'un des
premiers bénévoles accueillir les
ukrainiens on veut pas les stigmatiser
c'est des gens qui fuient la guerre et
on veut les accueillir du mieux possible
des invités dont le sort a ému bien des
gens est mobilisé beaucoup d'énergie
rapidement on a un magasin
d'alimentation gratuit on alloue
droguerie gratuite on a la téléphonie
mobile gratuite on a internet gratuit on
aa les sanitaires gratuit
ici les ukrainiens peuvent prendre et
donner des nouvelles permettre aux
enfants souffle y dormir un peu en
attendant le prochain train dans
l'entrée de la gare une véritable
cantine où l'on sert toujours des repas
chauds et parfois avec le sourire au
début les gens
manger par terre dans le hall de la gare
et je trouve que c'était totalement
indécent qui au 21e siècle en 2022 des
gens mangent par terre à même le sol une
attention qui contraste avec les
horaires imposés aux ukrainiens cette
mère et sa fille ont passé par la gare
elle tente maintenant d'obtenir un visa
pour le canada leurs cous et venu de
tours autour pour les aider à naviguer
les ou de l'exil
constantin rabinovitch n'a que des bons
mots pour les polonais qui ont aidé sa
famille
l'hébergement et la nourriture qu'on
leur a offert même le transport gratuit
tous passent mieux et plus vite qu'il ne
l'imaginait
la nuit dernière sa cousine et sa nièce
ont enfin dormi sans crainte ce sont les
sirènes d'alerté
mais les missiles tombent toujours sous
l'ukraine et lettres qui lui d'arriver
en pologne kuba tchaïkovski et des
milliers d'autres gardons les bras
ouverts accueillent leurs voisins un
effort qui se veut aussi un pied de nez
à l'envahisseur ça va fort pour nous
souder entre polonais et ukrainiens
c'est tout le contraire de ce que
l'homme qu'on veut pas donner le nom
voulait faire quoi ils voulaient nous
désunir et
il a obtenu une foule contraire c'est
dommage qu'ils aient autant de victimes
civiles dans cette guerre ici et légumes
au bar aurait dû canada varsovie